dans la rue piétonne de Vendôme
l'épicerie Bernard due ou de ses 120 ans
résiste au monde moderne ce matin
Andress et sa légendaire blouse bleue
recevait ses produits phares tout droit
venu d'Espagne ah c'est le nougat
espagnol que nous nous en vendons toute
l'année mais cette qualité-là est un
petit peu supérieur alors il y a le
tendre et le dur voilà Amanda tiers ou
amandes moulu les fondateurs de
l'épicerie les voici les grands-parents
d'andresse arrivent et des Baléares en
1902 ils sont alors les premiers à
proposer des oranges et des bananes au
vent de moi
donc comme les bananes arrivent vertes
alors donc est-ce que c'est des
cornichons voilà ça c'est la grande
chose
c'était vert quand André sa 17 ans il
reprend l'épicerie il va y consacrer sa
vie sans jamais être aidé par un
ordinateur le millier de références il
les a dans la tête je fais tout à la
main voilà avec des le stylo bille
ta mère écrivait avec la pluie
watervalle vous savez l'autre mais bon
là là alors on s'amuse un petit peu les
représentants de commerce et dit oui
il y en a plus beaucoup de commerces
téléphone quand même pour certaines
choses sur l'histoire familiale sur les
produits sur son pays d'origine Andress
est un tarissable
voilà voilà
la rigueur aura c'est là et pour les
clients entrer dans cette épicerie et
beaucoup plus qu'un acte d'achat
[Musique]
pour moi authentique
hors du temps qu'on voit pas partout
il y en a pas sur Angers j'en ai pas vu
j'en connais pas et en plus une petite
aussi ancienne c'est vraiment
particulier mais voilà à 76 ans Andress
fatigue pouvoir emmener tout ça
maintenant ça vient d'arriver mais je
m'y attendais pas mais on va pouvoir le
l'emmener en réserve voilà alors trois
heures par jour Edgar retraitée vient
arrondir sa pension en donnant un coup
de main une aide précieuse qui permet à
Andrès de tenir encore mais jusqu'à
quand l'épicier au sourire malicieux
rêvent qu'en couple viennent racheter
son épicerie son seul espoir que l'âme
de sa boutique demeure et qu'il se
repose un peu